se cumple un mes de paro nacional en
colombia la propuesta de una reforma
tributaria del gobierno fue el
desencadenante que desató la indignación
de un país donde más del 40 por ciento
de la población vive en la pobreza los
del poder no quieren escuchar por eso
seguimos aquí con resistencia la reforma
económica cayó así como el ministro de
hacienda que la impulsó pero el paro ya
no iba solo de eso sencillamente no se
alteran las reglas de juego en esa
materia que tiene hoy el país cayó la
reforma de salud y cayeron otros
funcionarios del gobierno como la
canciller y el alto comisionado para la
paz que ejercía como negociador con un
comité nacional del paro en el que
muchos jóvenes no se sienten
representados sin embargo el ministro de
defensa responsable también de la
policía sobrevivió a una moción de
censura en el senado aunque el uso
desmedido de la fuerza por parte de las
autoridades ha aumentado la indignación
ciudadana y ha centrado las críticas
internacionales hacia el gobierno
colombiano que aún no recibe visitas de
organismos internacionales
warwick ya hemos recibido informes y
hemos sido testigos de un uso
de la fuerza por parte de los cuerpos de
seguridad disparando munición real y
dando palizas a manifestantes según la
ong temblores se cuentan 43 homicidios
cometidos presuntamente por la fuerza
pública en el marco de las protestas
mientras el gobierno mantiene una
supuesta infiltración por parte de la
guerrilla en las marchas sin un panorama
claro para el futuro de las
negociaciones el gobierno insiste en el
levantamiento de los bloqueos de
carreteras en barrios periféricos y
ciudades como cali epicentro de actos de
violencia como el ataque a la minga
indígena las demandas sociales se
mantienen en el país entero estudiantes
feministas indígenas pensionistas piden
un cambio sistémico